[Música]
las autoridades de Ucrania alertan de
nuevos ataques rusos sobre gerson la
ciudad que las tropas de Moscú
abandonaron hace dos semanas el ejército
ruso mantiene la ofensiva contra la red
energética de Ucrania y gran parte del
territorio no dispone de suministros
básicos Pedro Castillo nombra a Betsy
Chávez como primera ministra de Perú
tras la renuncia de Aníbal Torres
algunos congresistas cuestionan el
nombramiento porque es investigada por
la fiscalía por delitos de corrupción
en pleno mundial de Qatar el mundo
recuerda al Astro del fútbol Diego
Armando Maradona el futbolista murió el
25 de noviembre de 2020 una figura
comprometida con el antiimperialismo y
la justicia social Pero acusado de
violencia machista y abuso de menores
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relativa a la guerra en Ucrania Rusia
mantiene y eleva su ofensiva contra la
red energética ucraniana como
consecuencia gran parte del territorio
permanece sin acceso a suministros
básicos por otro lado un nuevo ataque
sacude jerson recordemos que el ejército
de Moscú abandonó la ciudad el pasado 9
de noviembre y que desde entonces ha
sido recuperada por las fuerzas de kiev
Sin embargo las tropas rusas permanecen
a escasos kilómetros de la urbe justo
del otro lado del río niéper y Desde esa
posición continúan atacando la ciudad
nuestra enviada especial Catalina Gómez
Ángel no reporta desde gerson
este ataque a este complejo Residencial
característico de la arquitectura en
Ucrania son edificios que rodean estos
pequeños parques aquí cayó en la noche
de ayer al menos dos misiles que mataron
al menos cuatro personas se habla de una
quinta y este hace solamente parte de
uno de los tantos ataques con misiles y
con otro tipo de artillería de las
fuerzas rusas que abandonaron la ciudad
a partir del 11 de noviembre después de
la presión de las fuerzas ucranianas sin
embargo están muy cerca de aquí están al
otro lado del río a un kilómetro y Desde
allí es esto atacan constantemente la
ciudad cada vez más en los últimos días
en el día de hoy ha sido constante y hoy
también volvieron a atacar no muy lejos
de donde nos encontramos en una
plazoleta que es muy céntrica de la
ciudad por allí entran todos los carros
que vienen de ciudades como y también
está cerca a supermercados y viviendas
de residencias de civiles allí cayeron
dos misiles que mataron otras dos
personas y esto ha llevado a que aumente
el temor en la ciudad muchas más
personas decidan abandonarlas en las
últimas horas Porque temen que estos
ataques no solamente continuarán sino
que se pueden hacer mayores en los
próximos días
vamos al Líbano porque los ciudadanos
intentan hacer justicia por su cuenta
para reclamar su dinero retenido en los
bancos desde hace tres años mientras
crece la ira en las calles por la
inacción de la clase política para
establecer un plan de recuperación
financiera ahora muchos se buscan
alternativas en las criptomonedas ante
el bloqueo de las cuentas bancarias etel
bonet nos cuenta más
escenas como esta se repiten
habitualmente los bancos libaneses ante
la desesperación de los depositantes de
no poder disponer de sus ahorros el 4 de
octubre la diputada Cintia zaraccir tuvo
que recurrir a la fuerza para retirar su
dinero retenido necesario para pagar un
tratamiento médico se encerró con su
cómplice el abogada dinabusur en la
oficina bancaria hasta que tuvo la suma
para los gastos médicos no nos dejan
otra opción No me arrepiento de lo que
hicimos fue un acto de humanidad Cintia
padece una enfermedad Crónica y por fin
ha sido operada y se está recuperando
mientras la situación no cambia seguirá
habiendo más allanamientos
el bufete abogados
defiende los derechos legales de los
depositantes y ahorradores libaneses
nuestros ahorros están atrapados desde
hace tres años en los bancos no hay una
visión o estrategia para la recuperación
económica del Líbano es una reacción
natural la gente quiere su dinero los
llevaneses no ven mejoría en la
situación económica ahora que el
parlamento libanés intenta pasar una
controvertida ley de control de
capitales la ira a los depositantes
crece en las calles Richard faraón tenía
la mayor productora de eventos en el
Líbano
el capital no vamos a dejar que la ley
de control de capitales sea aprobada
nuestros gobernantes quieren acabar con
nosotros matar la economía destruir el
país el correcto puesto por los bancos
que limita el retiro de efectivo a 100
dólares semanales sumado al cierre
indefinido de la sucursales bancarias
tras la ola de asaltos ha llevado a cada
vez más libaneses a recurrir a la
criptomoneda para poder pagar sus
compras y recibir remesas extranjeras
nosotros damos una alternativa confiable
a la gente corriente para que puedan
disponer de recursos a través de
nuestros servicios de cripto carteras
digitales
somos después de Turquía el país de
oriente medio con más transacciones de
criptomoneda
la peor crisis financiera de su historia
si mejores perspectivas para el futuro y
sin gobierno el Líbano no podrá recibir
los tan necesitados 3.000 millones de
dólares de ayuda del fondo monetario
nacional para el rescate financiero y
los ciudadanos seguirán sin poder
acceder a sus ahorros
en otras noticias la justicia francesa
amplió la investigación existente por
presunto fraude fiscal contra la
consultoría estadounidense mckenzie
según reportes del diario leparición la
fiscalía nacional financiera abrió una
pesquisa por supuesto favoritismo y
presunto financiamiento ilegal de la
campaña presidencial de Manuel macron en
2017 la fiscalía confirmó que la
investigación se amplió para estudiar
ahora el rol de la consultoría también
en la campaña de 2022
dos investigaciones en marcha con
repercusiones potencialmente dañinas
para el presidente francés la fiscalía
de París anunció que había iniciado
investigaciones sobre el uso y
contratación de consultoras de gestión
durante la campaña presidencial de 2017
al igual que la de 2022 aunque no se
menciona por su nombre se cree que
Emmanuel maccón y sus vínculos con la
empresa estadounidense Mackenzie son uno
de los focos de las pesquisas los
vínculos de la empresa con el presidente
han sido criticados desde hace tiempo
las investigaciones se centrarán en las
acusaciones de posible falsificación de
la contabilidad de la campaña electoral
y de infravaloración de sus gastos así
como de posible favoritismo el gobierno
solo se limitó a reconocer las
investigaciones
el Eliseo toma nota de la apertura de
las dos investigaciones judiciales se
indica también que corresponde a la
justicia llevar a cabo estas
investigaciones con total Independencia
el uso de consultorías se puso en el
punto de mira en marzo tras una
investigación del senado francés que
concluyó que el gasto público alcanzó
más de mil millones de euros solo en
consultoras el año pasado y se produce
en medio de las denuncias de que
consultores del grupo estadounidense
Mackenzie trabajaron gratis en la
campaña de macron de 2017 Francia tiene
normas estrictas sobre la financiación
de las campañas que ponen límites a lo
que un candidato puede gastar varios
políticos franceses han sido
investigados a lo largo de los años
justo por gastar en exceso como el
presidente Nicolás sarkozy que en
septiembre del año pasado fue condenado
a un año de prisión por la financiación
ilegal de su candidatura a la reelección
en 2012
en China los principales dirigentes del
país recibieron al presidente de Cuba
Miguel Díaz canel quien realiza una gira
internacional para afianzar las
relaciones económicas con varias
naciones amigas antes de llegar a China
el mandatario cubano pasó por Argelia
Rusia y Turquía Rafael Pérez nos cuenta
más
una gira clave y necesaria en un
contexto económico complejo el
presidente cubano fue recibido en China
por su homólogo en la última parada de
Super diplo internacional
Beijing es uno de los principales
aliados de La Habana por lo que la
visita Tuvo una connotación
principalmente económica y simbólica el
señor presidente es el primer jefe de
estado de los países de América Latina y
el Caribe que visita china después del
vigésimo Congreso Nacional del partido
comunista Chino lo que refleja la
especial relación amistosa entre las dos
naciones
anteriormente el jefe de estado caribeño
sostuvo un encuentro en Turquía con el
presidente
receptayberdoan evaluamos las
oportunidades para desarrollar la
cooperación existente en Campos como la
energía el turismo la construcción la
agricultura el desarrollo la salud y el
medio ambiente
arquelia y Rusia también fueron parte
del trayecto la cancelación de los
servicios de la deuda de laplazamiento
de su pago fue una de las decisiones más
importantes de su visita argel y el paso
por Rusia reforzó la unión de ambos
países en un frente común
le hacemos en un momento en que ambos
países ambas naciones tanto Rusia como
Cuba están sometidas a sanciones
injustas arbitrarias que proceden y
tienen su origen el mismo enemigo el
Imperio Yankee que ha manipulado también
a una parte importante
regresará Turquía allí sostendrá un
encuentro con varios empresarios turcos
antes de retornar a la Habana
el presidente de Perú Pedro Castillo
nombró este viernes como primera
ministra a Betsy Chávez quien hasta el
momento se desempeñaba como titular de
cultura se trata de un nombramiento
cuestionado por algunos congresistas
dado que Chávez es investigada por la
fiscalía por delitos de negociación
incompatible aprovechamiento del cargo y
tráfico de influencias Chávez se
convierte en la quinta presidenta del
Consejo de ministros desde que Castillo
asumió el poder en julio de 2021 eso
tras la renuncia presentada por Torres
ante la decisión de la mesa directiva
del El Congreso de rechazar el
planteamiento de un voto de confianza
que él hizo la semana pasada
continuamos en nuestra región porque
tras la primera semana de diálogos el Ln
y el gobierno de Colombia dan a conocer
sus avances vía un comunicado en que
aseguran que las conversaciones se dan
en un ambiente de optimismo y de
confianza en un primer punto las partes
acordaron ratificar la presencia como
garantes de Venezuela Cuba Noruega la
ONU y la Iglesia Católica además se
invitaron a participar a México chile y
Brasil y buscan la disposición de
Estados Unidos por otro lado gobierno y
eln acuerdan retomar el punto de medidas
de alivio humanitario y finalmente Crean
un equipo de comunicación conjunta para
anunciar los avances del diálogo
acciones y hoy 25 de noviembre se
conmemora el día de la eliminación de la
violencia contra las mujeres y las niñas
según la Organización Mundial de la
Salud aproximadamente una de cada tres
mujeres en todo el mundo sufre violencia
física y sexual sin embargo más allá de
la violencia física las redes sociales
han abierto un nuevo espacio que también
es escenario de violencia de género
sobre todo psicológica previamente
hablamos con sucia alegre abogada de
Derechos Humanos
Pues ahí hay varios riesgos o lo que se
ve son como acosos y ataques online
cuando mujeres por ejemplo con un perfil
público
se expresan online que las respuestas Y
los ataques que reciben tienen un
carácter misógino que puede tener un
carácter como muy violento como amenazas
de violación por ejemplo amenazas de
violencia en la vida real pero que se
transforman como como
a un nivel mucho más
desarrollado de lo que se vería en la
vida real por un lado porque
los acosadores se sienten protegidos por
internet Así que como que no hay límites
en lo que se pueda hacer también la
forma por ejemplo de revelar datos
personales de las mujeres online o sea
por una forma de ataque de acoso que si
se quiere realmente dar miedo o sea
poniendo por ejemplo una dirección de
una mujer online puede llamar la
atención y puede llamar una violencia
física también para las niñas o sea las
niñas y también mujeres el problema de
pornografía de venganza por ejemplo O
sea la posibilidad de de compartir
fotos íntimas a todo el mundo no O sea y
y la posibilidad también de de crear
defectos se de crear fotos que parecen
ser de una mujer pero que no lo son
Realmente y esas imágenes de forma
pornográfica y creo que realmente el
problema fundamental es esa posibilidad
de compartir por todo el mundo o sea y y
la inhabilidad O sea de parar
la forma en que esas imágenes o que es
esas cosas
se transforman en algo mundial y
cerramos en Qatar donde ex compañeros de
Diego Armando Maradona le rindieron
homenaje en el día en que se cumplen dos
años de su muerte considerado uno de los
mejores futbolistas de la historia
Maradona murió a los 60 años el 25 de
noviembre de 2020 Y a esta hora continúa
abierto el caso contra ocho personas de
su equipo médico por posible negligencia
el Astro del fútbol fue una figura
estrechamente vinculada al socialismo y
alante imperialismo de Estados Unidos
sin embargo también fue acusado de
violencia machista y abuso de menores
dos años después de su muerte el mito de
Maradona vive en la memoria de los
aficionados del fútbol así lo recordó el
presidente de la conmebol
ella es inmortal y él no podía faltar en
este mundial por eso está con nosotros
aquí presente y siempre va a estar en
cada uno de todos los corazones de los
que amamos el fútbol de buena manera así
que muchas gracias Un beso al cielo para
Diego
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros
[Música]